right now we're in the model room of the
lower level of the San Francisco Museum
of Modern Art surrounded by half-inch
scale models this was a unique
experience because we are installing
also the floors of the museum we had to
make the model and maquettes for all
seven floors
that allows curators to have a
conversation around the models and when
the characters decide what goes where it
allows them to discuss and tangibly move
the objects
the first thing that we do is come up
with a list of works of art that we'd
like to install then we pass that list
to our model maker and she creates tiny
little Mac hats they're a half an inch
to a foot and and then we begin to work
with them in a scale model of our
galleries once the works of art are laid
out in the gallery then we work on
refining the placement and the spacing
curators are committed to having their
exhibitions their galleries be as
effective as possible that often
involves a very very close attention to
seemingly very small details
the museum will have 1900 works on view
when it opens I had to make about 2500
to 3,000 works it took me 3 to 4 years
to make all them again technically I
don't have to be so detailed I want the
curators to be able to imagine the space
more clearly so a lot of work many of
the artworks are complicated to make but
the most challenging I find are the
abstract sculptures that the artist
organically created because when I
recreate them no matter how careful I am
with the measurements because it's so
deliberate and ends up looking nothing
like the work okay ready on three one
two three good okay all right so
steadying other people to start
unwrapping it's like Christmas but you
already know what they're getting
when I go into the galleries after I
make a scale model the work seems
gigantic and it looks even more
magnificent hanging a piece of art is
art in itself
it takes a lot of thought process and a
lot of people to take a work apart I
think it takes artists to understand
artists a visitor would know that we did
our job well if they are delighted and
amazed by the work that they see without
thinking about cables without thinking
about smudges on the wall and without
bumping into anything that would
distract them from their experience of
seeing the world
our job is to make it look like we were
never there
you